اهلا بكم الى شجره الرابعه من الرياض
والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات
السعوديه والخليج اليكم العناوين
الحكومه الالمانيه تؤكد تكفيف الجهود
الدوليه لزياده الضغط على ايران بسبب
الاحتجاجات
مقالب
يدعو الحكومه البريطانيه الى تعزيز
مصالحها وعلاقاتها مع دول الخليج
ولي العهد السعودي علي نضم مشروع الدرعيه
الى مشاريع صندوق الاستثمارات العامه
الكبرى
في الرابعه ايضا
ملفات عديده عالقه وجدل النيابي في الكويت
يسبق انعقاد الجلسه الاولى لمجلس الامه
الجديد
وزاره الحج السعوديه توقع اتفاقيات مع
تسعه عشره وفدا لترتيب استعدادات الحج
القادم
مساء الخير اعلانات الحكومه الالمانيه عن
تكثيف الجهود الدوليه مع الشركاء لزياده
الضغط على النظام الايراني وذلك مع تصاعدي
حده المعارضه الدوليه لعمليات الاعدام
التي ينفذها النظام ضد المحتاجين واضافه
الحكومه الالمانيه ان العالم يريد ان يبين
لايران نتيجه افعالها ضد المحتاجين في
مقاله الخارجيه الالمانيه ان هناك خطوات
للموافقه على حزمه اضافيه من الاجراءات ضد
ايران
ضع المستشار الالماني اولى فشلت السلطات
الايرانيه لوقف تنفيذي اي عقوبات اعدام
بحق المتظاهرين كما حتى شيلت طهران على
اطلاق سراح المعتقلين بشكل فوري مشيرا الى
ان النظام الايراني ينفذ اعدامات كوسيله
للقمع
المرشد الايراني علي خامنئي وصف
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في البلاد بانها خيانه
كبيره لايران ودعاء امام حشد من انصاره
مؤسسات الدوله الى التعامل بشكل حازم وجاد
ضد ما وصفها بالخيانه من قبل المتظاهرين
وقرر خانني زعمه ان الاحتجاجات تقف خلفها
مؤامرات خارجيه هدفها تدمير ايران
في مقال له على صحيفه ذي التلغراف
البريطانيه دعا الكاتب سيمون ميول الحكومه
البريطانيه الى تحديد مصلحتها الوطنيه في
صميم اهداف سياستها الخارجيه وتبني تقييما
اكثر واقعيه وعلميه بشان تحديد الاعداء
والاصدقاء خصوصا في ظل السلوك العدواني
لايران كما دعى الكاتب لندن الى ضروره
اعاده النظر في العلاقه مع دول الخليج
والتي وصفها بالجزيره بالثناء والمستحقه
للدعم سيمون وصفا في مقاله ايران بالدوله
المشكله للخطر في المنطقه من خلال استخدام
ميليشياتها وتمويلها
من لندن ينضم الينا الباحث في العلاقات
الدوليه الدكتور احمد عجاج اهلا بك معنا
دكتور في نشره الرابعه بدايه لنتحدث عن
هذا المقال والذي يركز على تعزيز العلاقات
للندن مع دول الخليج وتحديدا السعوديه
ربما اين تكمن نقاط الالتقاء بالمصالح بين
السعوديه والمملكه المتحده دكتور
اولا يعني على العلاقات السعوديه
البريطانيه هي علاقات متميزه يعني ليس
الان يعني منذ نشات المملكه وحتى الان لكن
اهميه هذا المقال انه يوجه الانظار مره
اخرى الى التغير الوضع جيوستراتيجي في
المنطقه وسايمون يعني ليس فقط مجرد كاتب
هو رجل عسكري من الطلاط الاول ويفهم يعني
التقلبات في المنطقه وهو مستشار سابق
لوزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ومستشار ايضا
لاحد البنوك المهمه لذلك اعتقد ان ما قاله
يعكس وجهه نظر يبدو انها تتزايد في الغرب
وهو ان منطقه الخليج هي جزء من الامن
الاوروبي وهي جزء من الازدهار الاوروبي
وانما وجد في منطقه الخليل وهذا ما قاله
الكاتب ان يعني حكام تلك المنطقه استطاعوا
ان يبرزوا يعني اهميه الحكم الرشيد من
خلال الطفره الاقتصاديه التي تشهدها
المنطقه هذه الطفره الاقتصاديه مهمه جدا
للغرب لكن الاقتصاد يحتاج الى الاستقرار
ومن هنا يقول ان منطقه الخليج عليها تسابق
يعني هناك شغف روسي بها هناك شغف صيني لو
لابد للغرب ان يحسم امره ويقرر اين يقف
لانه هناك تهديد لهذه المنطقه من ايران
وبالتالي على الغرب ان لا يكون خجولا ولا
يتباطئ بل يقولها علانيه ويوقف الموقف
الصريح من هذه
الازمه التي تشهدها منطقه الخليج بسبب
وجود المليشيات المدعومه ايرانيا وبسبب
البرنامج النووي الايراني
موقف الحكومه البريطانيه الحاليه من
الحكومه الايرانيه والنظام الايراني
ومليشيته في المنطقه هل يمكن ان نرى
التعامل مختلف للحكومه الحاليه تجاه ايران
نعم نعم سنشهد تعامل يعني مختلف تماما نحن
تحدثنا يعني سابقا عبر قناتكم حول توجه
بريطاني لتصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه
ارهابيه وهذا بذاته تحول خطير جدا في
النظره الى ايران لان الحرس السوري وجزء
من المؤسسه الامنيه الايرانيه وهناك هذا
التحول البريطاني يجري في سياق تحول
اوروبي ايضا يعني هناك مشروع قرار في مجلس
الشيوخ الفرنسي ايضا بوضع الحرس الثوري
على قائمه الارهاب ووضع عقوبات جديده على
ايران ووقف التفاوض معها بشان السلاح
النووي وكذلك في في كندا حيث قال يعني
رئيس الوزراء الكندي في تابينه لضحايا
الذين طائر الذي التي قصفها الحرس الثوري
الايراني قال ان الحكومه الايرانيه لا
تمثل الشعب الايراني وهذه مقوله خطيره جدا
مما يعني انه يمكن ان يسحب التمثيل
الدبلوماسي الايراني وهو ما تطالب به
المعارضه الايرانيه اذا بريطانيا في
التحولات التي نشهدها هي لا يمكن ان تتاخر
عن ذلك ولديها حاسه استشعار اقوى من
الاخرين لذلك سنغراها تتشدد اكثر من خلال
هذه الامور وهذه المقاله الكاتب التي
يكتبها في صحيفه الداليه جراف وهي مقرب
هذه الصحيفه من الاوساط الحكوميه انما
تعكس التفكير الذي على المستشد لدى صناعه
القرار في بريطانيا
هذا التشدد يحدث من الدول الاوروبيه كيف
يمكن ان يؤثر على النظام الايراني وقرارات
النظام الايراني من باب المليشيات من باب
القمع على المتظاهرين وما الى ذلك
سيؤثر كثيرا يعني هناك عاملان مهمان في
العلاقات الدوليه عامل داخلي وعمل خارجي
ايران الان تواجه ازمه داخليه تواجه شعب
يشكك في مشروعيه هذا النظام لان الشعب
الذي يثور في الشوارع يطالب باسقاط النظام
ويصف يعني زعيم النظام وهو المرشد الاعلى
بانه ديكتاتور والنساء
طيب نشكر ااا الدكتور احمد عجاج الباحث في
العلاقات
الدوليه لهذه المداخله يبدو اننا فقدنا
الاتصال معهم
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها
تواصل عملياتها الهجوميه على طول خط
التماس في دنيتك واشارت في بيان لها ان
العمليات الهجوميه تتقدم في اتجاه سوليدار
وبخمود حيث تدور معارك عنيفه ضد القوات
الاوكرانيه واضافت ايضا انه تم استهداف 89
وواحده مدفعيه تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه
واسقاط ثمان طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه
قالت اوكرانيا انها تعزز قواتها في من
تقدم باز شرقي البلاد وتصد الهجمات
المستمره التي تشنها مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
الخاصه على بخموت وبلدات اخرى هناك واضافه
السلطات الاوكرانيه ان التعزيزات ارسلت
الى سوليدار بالقرب من باخمود مشيره الى
ان روسيا اقحمت وحدات اكثر احترافيه من
مجموعات
مراسل العربيه
حيث تعتبر البلدان مركز نقل الاستراتيجيا
هام لتزويد تجمع القوات الاوكرانيه في
دمباز حيث تمر عبر هذه المدينه شبكه من
الطرق والسكك الحديديه
اعلن ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان عن ضم مجروح مشروع الدرعيه للمشاريع
الخمسه الكبرى والمملوكه لصندوق
الاستثمارات العامه ليصبح واحدا من
المشاريع الفريده من نوعها على مستوى
العالم وتضم منطقه الدرعيه السعوديه معالم
ثقافيه وتراثيه وسياحيه من ابرزها حي
الطريف التاريخي والمدراج على قائمه
اليونسكو للتراث العالمي
هنا قلب على مساحه سبعه كيلو مترات مربع
تاسست عاصمه الدوله السعوديه الدرعيه قبل
300 عاما تقريبا بتصميم نجدي طينيا مزخرف
بمثلثات من الجس الابيض مشروع تطوير
الدرعيه الذي اعلن ضمه الامير محمد بن
سلمان للمشاريع الكبرى اليوم يعد اضخم
مشروع تراثي حضري تم الاعلان عنه حتى الان
وذلك لحساسيه وصعوبه التعامل مع المباني
القديمه
من اصول المشروع الرئيسيه شمالا يقع حي
طريف والذي سيحتضروس سته متحف منها متحف
قصر سلوى ومتحف الخيل والمال والعماره
الساحات المحيطه بالحياء او يمكننا
تسميتها مداخل الحي ستتحول الى سوق مفتوح
الانحراف والبضائع ولزياده الج همم
مشاهدينا ستعتمد واجهه قصر سلوى لتكون
شاشه تفاعليه بالصوت والضوء وذلك
لاستخدامها في عرض الافلام الوثائقيه
التاريخيه والاحتفالات المصاحبه الى الشرق
وحيوا البجاري المرتفع عن حي طريف والذي
جرى افتتاحه مؤخرا يمتد على مساحات صخريه
منحدره ليكون مطلا طبيعيا مثاليا
للاستجمام فوق مخطط هيئه تطوير البوابات
الدرعيه سيكون متنزها مفتوحه عبر ممشى
بطولي ثلاثه كيلومتر هذه المماشي مشاهدينا
المضلله تحيط ب 20 معلما ثقافيا يمكن
زيارتها عبر مسارات او مساراتي للدراجات
ايضا والاضافه الطابعه الحضاري مشاهدينا
للمنطقه ستكون اكبر نقطه جذب للمطاعم
العالميه من فئه مش لانسر في المملكه
بالاضافه الى معهد فنون اقليمي معتمد
وفندق
الى اخر اصول المشروع الثلاث وهو وادي
حنيفه المجرى المائي الوحيد في العاصمه
الرياض وهو احد اكبر مصارف الامطار
والسيول في البلاد يبلغ طوله 120 كم
متنزهات مفتوحه صديقه للبيئه وبها مشاكل
ومطاعم ومراكز تخدمها هذا الغرض لتسهيل
وصول الزوار المشاهدين خصصات الهيئه وخاصه
الهيئه ساحه انتظار تستوعب نحو احد عشر
2000 سياره وخططت لانشاء ثلاثي محطات
رئيسيه لمتر الرياض احداها مرتبطه بالمطاي
مباشره اما حجم المردود الاستثماري
للمشروع مشاهدينا فيقدر في 75 مليار وصولا
لعام 20/04 و20 والى المردوده الاجتماعيه
لاهل المنطقه فسوفر المشروع خمسه وخمسين
الفا جديده
[موسيقى]
من طريف الى جده ولكن انطلقت فيها فعاليات
معرض اكسبو الحاج بمشاركه مختلف القطاعات
الحكوميه ووفود دوليه اكسبوا الحج يهدف
الى بناء منظومه متكامله ومستدامه لتطوير
تجربه الحجاج كما شهد المعرض توقيع
اتفاقيات بين وزاره الحج والعمره وبين 19
وفي الدولي لتنظيم استعدادات موسم الحج
لهذا العام الجاري
من معرض اكسبو الحاج بجده ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه سلطان السلمي اهلا بك معنا
سلطان اذا ما ابرز الاهداف لهذا المعرض
وما الجديد الذي اتى به لحج هذا العام
بكافه المشاهدين قناه العربيه نتواجد داخل
اروقه هذا المعرض الذي يحكي
الخطط الاستراتيجيه والافكار والمبادرات
والمشاريع التي تخدم الحجاج بشكل مباشر
وكذلك المعتمرين في المشاعر المقدسه من
كافه الخدمات النوعيه التي تقدم وتقدم
للحجاج بشكل مباشر وحتى كذلك المعتمرين
ورينا ياخذكم معي في جوله داخل هذا المعرض
الذي يشارك فيه قرابه المئتين وعشره جهه
بين القطاع العام والقطاع الحكومي ممثله
بكافه القطاعات الحكوميه والخاصه التي
ترتبط بشكل مباشر فيما يتعلق بخدمه الحجاج
ابرز ما ابرز ما هو ما هو ملفت هذا العام
هنا في اكسبو في نسخته الثانيه هي
المبادرات والمشاريع والافكار الجديده
نتحدث على الريبورتات الجديده واستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي والتقنيات الحديثه في
كافه المجالات المرتبطه بالحجاج من ناحيه
الخدمات
متعلق بالخدمات الصحيه وكذلك الخدمات
التوعويه والارشاديه في هذا المعرض هذا
العام هنالك شركات تقنيه همم كبيره ده
مشاركه في المعرض شركات التموين وشركات
الاغذيه المشاركه القطاعات الحكوميه كلها
تشارك اليوم ابرز المشاريع المشاركه في
هذا المعرض او الابتكارات اليوم هو
المطوفه والموظف الرقمي الخاص بشركات الحج
داخل هنا اليوم هنالك تطبيق او موقع او
موظف رقمي يعمل على خدمه الحجاج من الداخل
ومن الخارج ومن خلال الاجابه على كافه
الاستفسارات من خلال معرفه المواقع وكذلك
الغرف السكنيه الخاصه وكذلك النسك وكيفيه
اداء الحج وايضا المراكز الحكوميه مثل
المستشفيات كما وقعها والاجابه بكافه
اللغات على كافه الاستفسارات ايضا موجود
هناك التقريات حديثه مشاركه في هذا المرض
من خلال التعرف على همم الوجه الحاج من
خلال تصوير الوجه عبر الكاميرا الامام
يستطيع من خلاله الجهات الحكوميه معرفه
اسم الحاج كامل ورقم الهويه وحتى رقم
الاقامه ومعلومات السكن وغير المعلومات
الخاصه ايضا هنالك استمرار في تطوير
المشاريع الذكيه الخاصه بوزاره الحج
والعمره من خلال الحج الذكي والعساوي
وكذلك البطاقات الذكيه المرتبطه التي
انطلقت العام الماضي والمستمره هذا العام
من خلال تطويرها ايضا فيما يتعلق بخدمات
اللوجستيه السكن اليوم هنالك سوف تكون هذا
العام روبرت الذكيه تخدم السكان هذه
الفنادق وهذه المخيمات من خلال تقديم
الخدمه لهم بشكل ذكي عبر وبورتات كذلك
نتحدث على وجود او النقلات النوعيه التي
حدثت في الحج قديما وحتى اليوم خلال
ابرازها عبر معارض ومتاحف وموجوده داخل
معرض داخل هذا المعرض ايضا الملفت كذلك
مشاركه القطاعات الحكوميه بمختلفه في
المجالات نتحدث على خطوط الطيران وكذلك
المطارات والوزارات التي تخدم ال- ال- ال-
ال- الحج الحج بشكل عام ايضا هنالك نقلات
نوعيه فيما تقل يتعلق بخدمات الاعاشه
اليوم الموجوده كذلك برامج التامين الصحي
للحجاج اليوم لا يدخل اي حاجه للسعوديه
الى بعد ان يتم التامين الصحي علي عبر
شركات كبيره وضخمه جدا اليوم تم توقيع
قرابه 56 اتفاقيه همم وقعها وزير الحج
السعودي الدكتور توفيق الربيعه همم مع
رؤساء وهمم
ولول والوفود المشاركه في حجه هذا العام
سوف تكون موجوده ايضا ممكن نظهر على شركات
الاعاشه التي امامنا الان كبرى الشركات
السعوديه المحليه وكذلك الخارجيه المشاركه
في خدمات الاعاشه تقدم وفق معايير ووف
كذلك اشتراطات دقيقه جدا نعم فقط
هذا العام مثل كل عام سيكون سلس
وميسر للحجاج ولكن هذا العام مع التقنيات
المستخدمه ستكون اكثر ثلاثه شكرا لك من
معرض اكسبو الحاج 20 23 في جده مراسل
العربيه سلطان السلمي
نشات الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها
مركز زراعه الاعضاء في تخصص الشرقيه يعلن
عن اجراء قرابه 280 عمليات نقل اعضاء
سنويه
حياكم الله من جديد يعقدوا مجلس الامه
الكويتي غدا جلسه الاولى بين البرلمان
الجديد والحكومه حيث سيتم
المناقشه عدد من القضايا
اسقاط القروض
موعدا لجلسه ساخنه تحت قبه عبد الله
السالم حيث تعقد جلسه بحضور السلطتين
الحكومه والبرلمان لمناقشه عدد من
القوانين والملفات العالقه بين سلطتين في
الكويت انشاء المدن والمناطق السكنيه
وتعديل احكام الامر الامريكي اضافه الى
ملف اسقاط القروض بنود مدرجه على جلسه يوم
الغد التي من المتوقع ان تشهد جدلا كبيرا
خصوصا فيما يتعلق بالقروض التي طلبت
الحكومه حولها مزيدا من الوقت للدراسه
ورغم حساسيه مقترح اسقاط القروض فقد قسم
المجلس ما بين مؤيد ومعارض للمقترح ووسط
هذا الجدل السابق لعقد الجلسه اصدر 22
نائبا بيانا شددوا خلاله على اهميه حل
الخلافات وفق العطور الدستوريه ملامحين
الى رفضهم لفكرته للمجلس شهد المتروك
بالعربيه
من الكويت ينضم الينا المحامي والباحث عبد
الكريم المجهول اهلا بك سيد عبد الكريم
معنا في نشره الرابعه نحن امام مجلس يعني
حكومه جديده مجلس جديد
وجلسه اولى من نوعها امام هذا التزم الذي
نشهده والخلاف ربما حتى على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي هل نحن امام همم
اختلاف في الحكومه او خلافات او حتى توتر
حياك الله استاذنا نحن امام اصطدام مبكر
بسبب قانون اسقاط القروض اللي يورط فيك
كثير من الاعضاء الموجودين والاغلبيه
البرلمانيه الحاليه في وعوده من
الانتخابيه المسجله صوتا ومرئيه على اسقاط
القروض والتخفيف عن كاهل المواطن وهي
مطالبات مستحقه ولكن تحتاج اليه معينه
لتحقيقه وليس
ولكن النواب هم الذين وضعوا الاغلبيه هم
الذين وضعوا نفسهم في هذا الملزق عندما
اخذوا يطالبون بمطالبات يعني على اطلاق
هجون دراسه مشاعر الناس والتسلق على عواطف
الناس الذي يسكنها الديون والاقتصاد
والجشع يعني ارتفاع الاسعار والجيش على
التجاره الذي لا يوجد اي رقابه حكوميه
للحد منها
فتورط كثير من النواب عندما اراد الناس ان
يحاكموهم الى ذات وعودهم اللي يطرقوها
اثناء عمليات الانتخابيه وفي مجالس
السابقه
استاذ عبد الكريم عن اسقاط القروض مثلا
اغلبيه النواب اللي موجودين في المسجد في
استعملت لهم يعني تصريحات صريحه في تاييد
اسقاط القروض التخفيف عن كائن الموا
طن شمه رئيس الوزراء اللي يستحق ان يعطى
وان يتعاون مع اراد فرصه ان يعني يحل هذه
القضيه عن طريق دراسه يعني ذات جدوى وتحقق
عداله قدر المستطاع ولكن بسبب محاكمه
النواب الى تصريحاتهم الذي كانوا فيها
يعني مصادمي الى احد ولا يساومون على هذه
القضيه اصبح النواب الان امام يعني مازقين
اما ان يعطوا سمو رئيس الوزراء فرصه لمزيد
من الدراسه فيقعوا في الثناء
عليهم واما ان يصادم الصدام المبكر فيقوده
والقياده الى حل المجلس او تحقيق الوعود
التي وصفها سمو ولي العهد بين شديده تتوقع
والحدث ولا احد
يعلمون
النواب وقعوا انهم لا يريدون ان يحدث
البرلمان وقعوا بانهم يريدون حل القضايا
وفق القانون
نعم ولكن الكثير من النواب اللي وقعوا على
هذا البيان كان لهم تصريحات مسبقه عدم
المساومه على حق اسقاط القروض والاذى ذلك
كثير منهم او عفوا منهم اثنين من
المواقعين تملصوا من هذا البيان وصرحوا عن
طريق حساباتهم انهم امام يعني اسقاط
القروض لامراه
الشارع عليهم حاده جدا ومحاوله يعني
محاكمتهم لتصريحاتهم
واخذ الكمر من هذا البيان
وهو بيان مستحق يعني سمو الشيخ احمد طبعا
لم يلطخ بتاريخ سياسي ككثير من الشيوخ
اللي وقعوا يعني دوامه الصراعات السياسيه
وهو شخصيه يملك تاريخ نزيه وزير الداخليه
كذلك يملك ثاني تاريخ نزيه يساعد على
اعطائهم فرصه ولكن ان تحاكم النواب وفق ما
اطلقوه من تصريحات ووعود ولذلك في نواب
صدقه في نواب حاليا صدقوا وانسجموا مع
انفسهم عندما
اخذ مثل النائب
ماجد المطيري كانهم موعود سابق او حاليا
يحاولون ينفذونها يعني
هذه المحاولات سيد عبد الكريم
احنا اذا حصلت الحكومه على اغلبيه معينه
حصلت على اصوات معينه للترحيل قانون
فكانوا يصاعدون عن طريق النزول الشارع
بكره اذا الحكومه مثلا وصلت يعني عدد
اصوات معينه ورحلت الموضوع هل صحيح
يساعدوني ينزلون الشارع كما المجالس
السابقه او راح يعني ينفرون الرماد على
العيون ويسجلون مواقف فقط لمغازله الشارع
ومحاولاتهم في انجاح ملف اسقاط القروض هل
ستنجح برايك وما توقعاتك لجلسه الغد في
ضلك كل هذه المتغيرات وكل هذه التازمات
ربما ما توقعاتك لجلسه الغد
انا اتوقع انه يعني السيناري يكثر احتمال
من الحكومه راح تتحصل على الاصوات اللي
يساعدها في ترحيل هذا الموضوع لمزيد من
الدراسه
ويعني خلق مناعه عقلاني يتم المجادله فيه
ووضع حلول يعني تتوافق مع الحكومه ومطالب
النواب ولا ولكن ترحيل هذا الموضوع سيضع
النواب اللي يعودوا الناس عندما تحصل
الحكومه كما حصل في المجال
السابع بعض المواضيع تعودت الناس منهم على
نزول الشارع والصدام والتصعيد فهل سيقوم
بذاته الفعل امنهم فعلا مؤيدين لترحينا
ولكن سجل وموقف بعد ان تاكد وان الحكومه
ستتحصل على عدد اصوات معينه هذا الفيديو
خلف الكواليس قاعد تعريه مواقف المواد
اللي لديهم صدام حاج في
اتفضل قانون قدر وغدا والتصويت عليه دون
يعني مواربه بالاسم حتى حدد بعض المواقف
قال يتم التصويت عليه بالاسم بدون مواربه
او يعني اي ضبابيه حتى يرى الشارع مواقف
النواب ويحاكمهم يلوعوذهم والحكومه
طيب الاستاذ عبد الكريم هذا الاصطدام
الحاد كما ذكرت حضرتك كيف تقيم على اثره
العلاقه المستقبليه بين الحكومه والبرلمان
النظام الديمقراطي نظام التصادم وليس
توافق وعاده عندنا الكل يزايد على الكل
والكل يريد ان يتدعم وهذه الحاله والعدام
القدره ضروري من الثقه وهي اللي تشكل
الارضيه الصلبه اللي يقف عليها البرلمان
والحكومه حتى يعني يتوافق يعني يستثمرون
المشتركات التي تصرف لصالح الوطن
الصراع الزعامات اللي عندنا وصراع يعني
الخطاب السياسيين وتدخل اصحاب النفوس سواء
من مثل ما يقال شيوخ والتجار كلها راح
يساهم في صدام المبكر لان ما احد كل فريق
من صالحه ان ان الاوضاع تستقر والحكومه
تعطى هناك فراخ اخرى مضاده لها من صالحها
ان تصعد وانت تحل البرلمان بعد ما الحكومه
فلا يوجد يعني توافق بين الفصائل السياسيه
صح التعبير لذلك اصطدام الاتي اتي وحته
محاوله اخفاه وهو مثل الرمادي يعني
مثلا الرومانسيه في اي لحظه شكرا لك من
الكويت المحامي والباحث عبد الكريم
المجهول
سعوديه تمكن اطباء مركز زراعه الاعضاء في
مستشفى الملك فهد التخصصي في الدمام من
اجراء عمليات نقل ثلاثه 1900 عضو
لمستفيدين في المنطقه الشرقيه واشتمالات
العمليات على زراعه الكلى والكبد
والبنكرياس اضافه الى استئصال الاعضاء
للمتبرعين الاحياء والمتوفيين دماغيا وذلك
منذ بدايه العمل في المركز عام 2008 ليكون
اجمالي ما تم زراعته في الشهر اكثر من 23
عمليه وبجموع 200 70 عمليه سنويا
الداخليه السعوديه اعلنت اكتمال المرحله
الثالثه لجواز السفر السعودي الالكترونيه
واتاحت تجديده للتابعيناه من هم اقل من 21
عاما وذلك من خلال منصه ابشر بشره الى
انها المرحله الاخيره لخدمتي اصدار وتجديد
الجواز السعودي الالكتروني عبر المنصه حيث
يمكن للمواطن الاستفاده من هاتين الخدمتين
اضافه الى التابعين لهم من منطقه
الاعمارهم عن 21 عاما عبر حسابه على منصه
ابشر ثم مراجعه اقرب فرع للجوازات لفحص
الجواز السابق من دون حجز مسبق
رابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها
هيئه التراث السعوديه تعلن تسجيل 41 موقعا
تراثيا عمرانيا في الطائف
السعوديه
اقل من اسبوع تبقى على معرض العطور بنسخته
الثانيه ضمن فعاليات موسم الرياضه حيث
يجمع المعرض اكثر من 150 علامه تجاريه
متخصصه في العطور اضافه الى زوار جاءوا
خصيصا له من مختلف الدول الخليجيه
والعربيه
اكثر من 150 علامه تجاريه تحت مظله واحده
في معرض العطور الذي انطلقت من فعاليات
الموسم الرياض ليستمر حتى التاسع من يناير
ليضم اكبر تجمع للعطور والشركات المتخصصه
وانا اتوقع الحين على دشره وبدايه اسبوع
المنتجاتنا موجود خصومات ان شاء الله
موجوده ونتشرف نلتقي بزباين السعوديه
عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي والمشاهير
كانوا حلقه الوصل بين المعرض والجمهور
الذين جاءوا للسعوديه للاستمتاع باجواء
الموسم وزياره المعرض عدد من السوشيال
ميديا الفنانين
في معرض العطار والصراحه احنا
تعملنا انا نقول ان هذا المعرض حلو او في
من كل البراندات ما شاء الله من كل دوله
يعني ما شاء الله مره واصل مره طاري كل
مكان كل حد يعني ما شاء الله قلنا معرض
العطور صراحه هنا عندكم مولع تجربه التسوق
الاستثنائيه في معرض العطور كشفت للزوار
عن خصومات وهدايا ومنتجات جديده
لمعرض العطور هذا العام لتتكرر زيارته
اكثر من مره من الرياض شهد المتروك العربي
[موسيقى]
السنه الكبيسه اطول من السنه البسيطه بيوم
واحد لان الحسابات الفلكيه لم تستطع
محاكاه دقه حركه الاجرام السماويه
التفاصيل في تقويم مع خالد ازعاج
[موسيقى]
نحن في الايام الاولى من السنه الميلاديه
20 23 وهي سنه بسيطه فعندنا سنين وبصائط
وسنين كبائس البسيطه عدد ايامها 365 يوما
ويكون فيها فبراير 28 يوما والكبيسه عدد
ايامها 366 يوما ويكون فيها فبراير 29
يوما وعدد السنين البصائق اكثر من السنين
الكبائث في التاريخ فكل اربع سنوات يكون
عندنا كبيسه واحده وثلاثه بصائر بمعنى ان
الذي يولد في يوم 29 فبراير لا يحتفلوا
بيوم ميلاده الا مره واحده كل اربع سنوات
ودي للطيبين مثلي مواليد واحد رجب واحد
سبعه لا يحتفلون في تاريخ ميلادهم ابدا
ليه لانهم ما يعرفون تاريخ ميلادهم من
الاصل لله جيل الطيبين كانوا كالطو ديما
ذل ولا استكانوا هم كالغيوم سابحات بدلا
وكالنخيل الباسقات
فضلا
[تصفيق]
وسنه الكبيسه اكبر من السنه البسيطه بيوم
واحد ليش لان الحسابات البشريه بين قوسين
التقاويم لم تستطع محاك الدقه حركه
الاجرام السماويه الشمس القمر الارض فيكون
فيها نسبه خطا مقداره ربع يوم في كل سنه
يجمع هذا الخطا ويجعل يوم واحد كل اربع
سنين سنين الجهد ان طالت ستطوى لها امد
وللامد انقضاء امانينا لها رب كريم اذا
اعطى سيدهشنا
العطاء
[موسيقى]
يوصلوا مهرجان شتاء طنطوره في العلا
السعوديه استقبال زواره حتى الثاني عشر من
فبراير حيث تقام العديد من الفعاليات
الفنيه والثقافيه المختلفه الموسم الرابع
من المهرجان حفل بباقه غنيه من الفعاليات
الموسيقيه على مسرح مرايا الايقونه والذي
يتمتع بواجهه هندسيه خلابه تعكس تاريخ
العلا وطبيعتها
تنضموا الينا من العلم وفدت العربيه نادين
خماش اهلا بك معنا نادين على نشره الرابعه
تطلين علينا من امام مبنى المرايا انقر
لنا ما الجديد لديك من العلا
اهلا بيكي فاطمه واهلا بمشاهدين نشره
الرابعه على العربيه اقف الان من احد اهم
معالم العلا قاعه مرايا التي تتوسط وادي
عطار في هذه المنطقه وادي بشار البيئي حيث
نشاهد قاعه مرايا الان والتي صنعت وصلنا
هذا المبنى باكثر من ثلاثه الاف لوح زجاجي
بمرايا عاكسه وهذه المرايا العاكسه نتحدث
عن عددها دخلت موسوعه جنس مرايا
صممت بخصوصيات محدده وهذه الخصائص لكي
تتحمل العوامل المناخيه والعوامل البيئيه
لان هناك ايام كبيره في السنه كثيره في
السنه نتحدث عن طقس بارد ولا تحدث ايضا
على الجفاف وايضا نريد ان يشير بان هذه
اللوحات الزجاجيه المرايا العاكسيه سعوديه
الصنع مئه بالمئه وبنتياس لماذا صنم هذا
المبنى
بالمرايا كما نشاهد كل المرايا من عندما
نت قاعه مرايا اذا اسم على مسمى صمم به
المرايا لكي لا تفقد هذه الطبيعه التي
تحيط بهذا المبلغ جماليتها لكي نعكس كل
طبيعه ما يدور حول هذا المبنى عندما نتحدث
عن هذه الطبيعه بالفعل يعني هناك امور
لافته نتحدث عن رمال كثبان رمليه وفي ذات
الوقت هناك تكونات للجبال بشكل جميل وايضا
غريب ولافت مثلا تابعوا معنا هنا هذه
الصخره وهذا الجبل فيه تكوين صخري لافته
وايضا جميل بالتالي هذه المرايا الموجوده
في مبنى قاعه مرايا هي تعكس كل هذه
الطبيعه الخلابه المتواجده وايضا علمنا
بانه سيتم ايضا وضع مرايا عاكسه في سقف
هذا المبلغ طبعا هذا المبنى اذا اردنا ان
نتصور ماذا يدور في داخل هذا المبنى هو
عباره عن مسرح وفيه ايضا قاعتان رسميتان
رئيسيتين وفي على سقف
المبنى قاعه المرايا يوجد مطعم عالمي طبعا
في فعاليات عده تتم في هذه القاعه وفي هذا
المبنى بالتحديد الى جانب العروض العالميه
والفنيه من كبار وكذلك المؤتمرات العالميه
نادين الغربي العام
طيب سنتحدث عن الاقبال ولكن ايضا نشير
بانه الى جانب كل الفنون الرسميه ايضا
هناك اجتماعات لي وزارات واشتماعات لوزراء
رسميه وايضا في اجتماعات لقاده دول نتذكر
ايضا هنا من امام هذا المبنى ومداخل هذه
المبنى حيث تم عقد ايضا بيان العلا من
خلال اجتماع قاده دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي واتمام المصالحه الخليجيه في
دورتها الحاديه والاربعين لدول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي في هذه القمه التي كانت
في العلاقه قبل عامين من الان اذا يعني هو
مزج يجمع بين الفن يجمع بين السياسه ويجمع
بين اهل الفن ويجمع بين اهل السياسه وايضا
الذوقين الذين يريدون الذهاب الى مطاعم
عالميه ويستكشف ايضا ما هو جديد في عالم
الطبخ وايضا في عالم الماكولات خصوصا اننا
نتحدث عن مطبخ مطعم عالمي في اعلى هذا
المبلغ طبعا بالحديث عن شتاء طنطوره
بالفعل نلاحظ بانه الاسود بدات منذ الايام
منذ بدا الاعلان عن الشتاء طنطوره حتى
عندما تشرين في الشوارع وفي المطاعم تلاحظ
لعدد كبير من السياح الاجانب الذين اتوا
الى العلا يريد ايضا ان يشاهده الى جانب
العجائب الطبيعيه والعجائب بفعل صنع
الانسان عندما تتحدث عن الاماكن الاثريه
للعلاهم ايضا يريد ان يحتفلوا بالعروض
الفنيه والمهرجانات وحتى ايضا فاطمه اذا
اردتم ان تشتروا تذاكر حسنا لدخول اي
فعاليات يعني معظم الاماكن التذاكر
التذاكر يعني منتهيه بفعل الحجم الكبير
والاقبال الكبير من قبل السياح وايضا من
قبل زوار من الداخل سواء من اهل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه او من خارج السعوديه
شكرا لك من العلم مفيده العربي نادين خماش
يشهدوا محافظات منطقه مكه بغرب السعوديه
موسما ممطرا انعكس على طبيعه المحافظات
التي اكتسبت باللون الاخضر نتابع
[موسيقى]
نذكر رب العناوين في نهايه النشره
الحكومه الالمانيه تؤكد تكثيف الجهود
الدوليه لزياده الضغط على ايران بسبب
الاحتجاجات
مقال في صحيفه يدعو الحكومه البريطانيه
الى تعزيز مصالحها وعلاقاتها مع دول
الخليج
ولي العهد السعودي يعلن ضم مشروع الدرعيه
الى مشاريع صندوق الاستثمارات العامه
الكبرى
ملفات عديده عالقه وجدل النيابي في الكويت
يسبق انعقاد الجلسه الاولى لمجلس الامه
الجديد
ووزاره الحج السعوديه توقعوا اتفاقيات مع
19 وفدا لترتيب استعدادات الحج القادم
ختام الرابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]